all right disgrace governor andrew
cuomo's nursing home scandal
is intensifying again it's now much
worse than we ever realized
according to an explosive report from
the new york times
cuomo's aide spent months trying to
cover up the extent of the nursing home
deaths
by hiding the true number not just from
the general public
but even from their own health officials
now
of course this was all happening at the
same time he was writing a book and
trying to take a victory lap for his
great covet response
so ask yourself what is it going to take
to hold
andrew cuomo accountable and why did joe
biden pick him
to lead the nationwide coveted response
here with reaction fox news senior
meteorologist janis dean
she lost family members as a result of
this executive order
your reaction janice
he continues to get away with it sean
unfortunately
and this was a bombshell report
basically saying they went to
great lengths to hide those numbers over
15
000 deaths in new york in nursing homes
and i believe it's because of his march
25th order to put covet positive
patients into nursing homes
for several weeks so the fact that the
new york times has a bombshell report
that's a big deal but i will tell you
that abc
cbs and nbc didn't cover it
all right so i do well i mean that's
standard fair right it's sad but it's
standard fair
uh if it was a republican if it was ron
desantis if it was governor abbott i
think it would be a different story
that's my opinion
uh now the question is there is an
alternative route
if there's not going to be justice in
the justice system
the families like your family
immediately impacted
do have the ability to go to the court
system i know that's been
in the works now for a while
we are talking about it i have a
discussion tomorrow with some lawyers
and we'll see how we can go forward
but i have to believe that justice will
eventually be served
sean there's an fbi investigation a
federal investigation
and the justice department investigation
that hopefully
is still in effect and not only the
nursing home issue but this guy has
other problems
uh with sexual harassment and covid
coveted tests for friends and family
for chris cuomo and his his friends when
nursing homes were begging for tests
families were begging for tests so that
they could see their dying loved ones
in their final days but governor cuomo
and his friends and family
got covent tests all right we're going
to stay on it we'll continue to follow
the updates as they become available
again we're sorry what happened to your
family members
uh janice dean thank you